this kitchen needs leadership and jazz
looks lost
the Russians reputation hangs in the
balance
all right government
ron's coolers go check on okay I need
the prawns plates don't want their
plates and wounded straight away in
Berea hurry up boys
get me the prawns are the prawns ready
give me the problems come on let's
create a nice their succulent full of
flavor get the common let's go finish
Jana hiya
okay next I need for Mickey chickens
with a piping hot we're getting dinner
some light in the kitchen not more
energy to kitchener more important your
man's in there so he's gonna put a rock
over us
table number fight the dishes are there
and now we're now we're fired up yeah
get that on what's up everybody
it was far from a perfect start but for
my diners the food has really hit the
mark Wow
smells amazing my food delicious I
normally go for the standard like creamy
curries but this was something completed
a nice to be asked for it to be milder
and they did it to perfection it's
stunning really
that was absolutely divine
probably the best curry I've ever had
how do you enjoy this
I love this Russians 40-year pedigree
but tonight I've only got it together
after a chaotic start okay
those starters took too long to leave
this kitchen 30 cover tonight felt like
300 covers it was a little bit too
casual but still it takes time yes
especially there's a nor'easter which
features a clam great from the stretch
not good enough this restaurant is not
used to sending out mediocre warm prawns
you take your prawn from that sand or
even and you stick it in there
game over you've got to command that
kitchen jazz on the out main causes
needed a rocket yeah you put your jacket
on bang and it turns the kitchen came to
life and there it was the old man at the
helm and here we go again there's that
fire in your belly
and you got it out don't get pissed off
not get eager to come back you're gonna
be even more strong enough thank you
good night it was a bit bit of a shock
to the system yeah you can still win
this we can't we will win good well done